welcome back everyone to my round eat
recap from the Reykjavik open this was
my shortest game of the tournament I
finished after about two and a half
hours which uh yeah it's pretty quick
for a classical game I've had multiple
games this tournament going up to almost
five hours so it's refreshing to have a
game finished so quickly uh but this
game I was playing a local player from
Iceland by the name of arnar malutin
hederson rated 2075 and before the game
I found a lot of his chess.com games and
tournament games and I was trying to
decide what opening to to go for between
mainly E4 D4 and C4 and I decided before
the game I would play an English opening
uh just to have something fresh and to
try and be a little bit less predictable
I have gone for the London twice so far
this tournament and both times I've gone
for it has not gone so well
so C4 it was and I was mainly preparing
for E5 and Knight F6 but my opponent
actually surprised me on move one with
the move Pawn C6
and this was a surprise because I knew
my opponent uh mainly plays like nimso
Indian type structures against D4 and he
also plays almost exclusively nidor of
Sicilian against E4 so I decided here to
play Pawnee 4 and try to transpose into
a variation of the Karo Khan which I
knew he doesn't play and after D5 takes
takes D4 which we got in the game this
is called the panel of baphunic attack
of the Carroll Khan and this used to be
actually one of my favorite openings
many years ago before I started playing
the London I really enjoyed the
positions that arise from this variation
and I used to have like studied and I
used to know a lot of the theory here
but it's been years since I've looked at
this position but I figured I would go
for it in the scheme because my opponent
uh would not be expecting it and it
would be very likely that I would have
more preparation than him and I knew I
made the right opening Choice after his
next move because he made a small
inaccuracy in this position the main
move for black is Knight F6 which is the
most natural and flexible but he went
ahead and took the pawn right away which
at first has some logic because Bach is
giving me the isolated d-pawn but uh
generally black should wait for the
bishop to develop before taking and that
way black can essentially win a Tempo
because I would have to move the bishop
twice but after he takes takes I
developed the bishop in one go and even
though I'm left with ISO Queen's Pawn
there's a lot of benefits to having the
pawn on D4 so I control more space in
the center and white has very easy
development so I was already happy with
opening and next few moves we both
develop after an eye of three I do set
up a small trap it would be a blunder
for black to play Bishop G4 white to
move and and when material move would be
Bishop F7 King F7 95
so we didn't go into that instead plan
E6 was played which looks a little bit
ugly because it blocks of Bishop but it
is necessary for black to complete
kingside development
so I played Knight C3 Bishop E7 castle
castle
and here I took my first a longer think
of the game the move I really wanted to
play was Pawn D5 which visually looks
pretty nice because it gets rid of the
iso pawn and after it takes takes takes
takes white has more development open
position my pieces are generally happier
but I decided not to go for this because
I thought after Knight C6 it's not so
clear if I have like a concrete Edge and
black is ready to play Bishop G4 and I
thought that maybe this would just
liquidate a bit too quickly and black
would have good chances to draw from
here
so instead I kept the imbalance in the
position and didn't play D5 but instead
played Knight to E5
and I was happy with this move because
it addresses one of Black's plans in the
position black really wants to play B6
in Bishop E7 and complete Queen side
development and get the nice long
diagonal for the light Square Bishop but
when I play 95 I'm actually preventing
B6 B6 would be a terrible mistake here
because it's met with Queen F3 hitting
the rook and essentially winning
material only way to defend is Knight D5
but after takes takes takes uh yeah box
position is just terrible rook and F7
are hit so white would be completely
winning there and the B6 can't be played
then it's much more difficult to
actually complete development of the
pieces Knight C6 is also kind of
discouraged because then I take and
napong gets weak on C6 so my opponent
opted for Knight D7 and then I played
Bishop to B3 which was mainly a flexible
move I was anticipating Knight B6 coming
so I figured why not move the bishop
back first and then after he plays
Knight B6 which he did then I can decide
what to do from here and I went for Rook
T1 he plays Knight D5 and I play Queen
to F3 so without remove I'm trying to
improve the pieces and try and get ready
for a king side attack that's a very
common plan for whites when you have the
Isley Queen's pawn it gives you more
space in the center which makes it
easier to attack on the king side and I
have ideas with Bishop C2 and Bishop G5
and queen H3 and eventually getting some
mating ideas and meanwhile black is
still a bit slow to develop and I should
note here that B6 still does not work
because of Knight C6 and the tactics are
all in White's favor if the queen moves
then I would take and uh yeah the
knights pinned and if the queen takes
and the pawn is pinned to the queen and
White's winning material essentially by
force after Knight C6
so after Queen F3 my opponent took a
pretty long think and played the move H6
which is somewhat of a waiting move kind
of a prophylactic move preventing Bishop
G5
and it put the ball in my courts like
how do I actually formulate an attack
because I did want to play Bishop G5
next move
another move I wanted to play was Bishop
C2 but I didn't want to run into Knight
B4 which hits the bishop and the d-pawn
so I decided to play Queen G3 first
aligning with the King and threatening
to take on H6 he played King h8 and then
from here I took a think because there
is a really interesting line that I was
close to playing but I couldn't quite
figure it out the move I wanted to play
was 94 which leads to some really crazy
variations because after it takes takes
there's all these ideas of sacking on
each six and Swinging The Rook over I
was looking at night
to F6 Rook H4 and I couldn't quite
figure out after Knight G8 if white has
a clear breakthrough on the king side
and I didn't want to commit my Rook to a
square like H4 if I'm not having a clear
uh way to to finish off the attack
so after a while I decided that why not
just complete development my bishop and
Rook are not in play and even though my
Bishop can't really develop to these
squares without being taken I decided
that Bishop D2 is a useful move just
preparing Rook D1 and then maybe even
later put the bishop back on C1 so their
Rook can support the pawn and with this
move I put the ball in Black's quartz
and uh my opponent played developing
move Bishop D7 which is definitely not
the ideal Square for the bishop but it
does aim to complete development maybe
get the Rook to c8s after Rook D1 my
opponent does play Rook C8
and then in this position I play the
move which I actually once I considered
I was very excited about because it
starts generating some nice tactical
threats that move being Queen to H3 this
applies a lot of pressure to Black and I
essentially played this move without too
much calculation but I acknowledged that
when I play Queen H3 there's a pretty
deadly idea of Bishop takes H6 and
there's so many lines where I just
sacked the bishop and then eventually
swing over and Checkmate on the kingside
combination with Bishop C2 and uh yeah
the knight in E5 it's very hard for
black to remove
so my opponent in this position I think
just addressed the threat of Queen H3
but he didn't address the other threats
it turns out Queen H3 is somewhat of a
double attack because not only am I
lining with a king I'm also aligning
with this bishop on D7 which in many
lines as a tactical Target because I'm
threatening Knight takes D5 and taking
advantage of the fact that the pawn is
being pinned so uh just to illustrate
the fact plays a waiting move here of
course I could take on H6 but I could
also take on D5 and if Knight takes D5
Bishop takes E5 I'm winning material on
D7 if Pawn takes D5 I take and Knight
takes I win the pawn and if Queen takes
I would take and win the bishop in the
end so
after I play Queen H3 the only move I
saw for black to try and address both
rats was Knight takes C3 and this was a
move I was expecting after which I would
take back and still have ideas of Bishop
H6
but we didn't go into that uh here my
opponents made a very bad blunder played
Knight H7 but I think this is sometimes
what happens when you're under a lot of
positional pressure after an opening
gone somewhat wrong it can be hard to
avoid the the Tactical blunders and even
though this is this address is one
thread of Bishop H6 it allows me to take
on D5 and white is just winning a clean
piece here he was clearly not happy when
I took on D5 and he thought for a little
bit took back I took the bishop and then
he resigned and after the game he told
me that this game will be my quickest
recap which I think will probably hold
true or at the what around 11 minute
Mark so
um yeah I don't think there's much more
to say about this game it was an opening
gone very nicely for me I think it was a
nice choice playing C4 getting my
opponent out of his comfort zone from
early on and and I think this is a nice
example of how to play with the iso
Queen's Pawn because there's many cases
where the pawn can be weak but there's
also many cases where the pollen can be
an asset and it can lead to a lot of
nice attacking ideas in the middle game
so hope you guys enjoyed this one uh
this was round eight there is one more
final round tomorrow I'm not sure when
I'm gonna get around to posting this
video because I'm a little bit behind
with my upload schedule but do stay
tuned for the final round recap I'm
going into round nine with five out of
eight points so hopefully I can finish
with a win and uh I'm just gonna take it
move by move tomorrow hopefully stay
awake and yeah stay tuned thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
I'll see you guys soon